welcome to today's developer update I'm
Jeff from the overwatch team I'm
particularly excited about this topic
because it's something that you guys
have been asking about for a very long
time in fact since the day we launched
you were asking for a way for us to save
highlights for you and we have done a
complete iteration and evolution of the
highlights feature so let me go into
some detail on how the new highlights
feature is going to work first off the
game will still continue to collect your
highlights as you play and suggest top
highlights for you it was doing this
previously where it would give you five
different highlights as you play it over
time and then allow you to play those
back well part of the problem was if you
logged out of overwatch or shot either
your PC or your console down those
highlights might go away
under the new system those top five
highlights will always be there for the
next 24 hours what's more is we've added
a new section called recently captured
and I should explain to you what exactly
this means so sometimes when you're
playing overwatch an incredible moment
will happen and you'll think to yourself
wow that should really be play the game
or I wish I had been recording that I
wish I could in some way capture that
moment well we've made it so that you
can either bind a key to capture a
highlight or you can bind multiple keys
on PC to capture multiple highlights so
the way this would work is very cool
thing happens in overwatch you think to
yourself wow that was amazing I wish the
game would remember that
so you basically bookmark it by pressing
your capture key and after the victory
or defeat screen happens the match is
registered and then that highlight will
go to your highlight section under
recently captured now when you go to
highlights you'll have those
auto-generated highlights under the top
five highlights of the day and your
recently captured highlights of which
you can have up to 32 once you fill the
32
highlights you're going to have to clear
some out now you're probably wondering
well what does clear some out mean we
have now given you the ability to save
highlights to a video file we call this
recording highlights the really cool
thing about this is it gives you
different options so if you're on a
console it will default to whatever
options your console defaults to to save
those video files then those video files
will go to whatever media library you
use whether it be the xbox media library
or the the playstation media library
however on PC these will go to a
directory for you in Windows now one of
the cool things that happens when you
use the highlights feature on PC is it
will give you options to record the
video in many different ways
so an example is you might plan a very
low end system that can't handle the
graphic settings being too high but if
you decide to you can output video like
let's say you're on Windows 10 you can
output video at 4k 60 frames a second
that just look amazing
now obviously the higher you set your
video settings for saving these
highlights the bigger that the video
files are going to be and the longer
it's going to take for the game to
generate that video file but if you opt
into it you can save some pretty amazing
looking really great highlights so we
think all of these new additions to the
highlight system will make it much
easier for you to capture and record
those great moments and even more so
then you can share them with your
friends on social media so we really
hope that you enjoy all of the new
updates coming to the highlights feature
I know it took us a long time to get to
them but it was something we were very
passionate about and we knew we could do
a lot of cool things with and we have
some other ideas of how to evolve it
even more so in the future now I wanted
to address one more topic very quickly
we are going to make significant
improvements to the loop box experience
one of the things that we're going to do
is drastically reduce the rate of
duplicates that you'll get out of any
loop box we think this will be
immediately evident and extremely
significant for all of our players and
we think it's going to feel fantastic
now one thing you might be thinking is
well if you reduce the amount of
duplicates I get what's going to happen
in terms of me earning credits and being
able to buy the things I want well to
compensate for this we're going to
increase the amount of credits that you
get out of loop boxes so we'll make sure
that your credit intake will be at least
the same if not more when all this is
done you won't see duplicate items
anywhere near as much and we really
won't encourage you to go on the PTR
check this out and feel it for yourself
you have to keep in mind that the system
doesn't have infinite content so at some
point you're obviously going to get
duplicate items you would need an
infinite amount of content to have no
duplicates but we think the change
should be very drastic and significant
and feel fantastic so we hope you enjoy
the highlights feature and we really
hope that the loop box changes feel as
great to you guys as they feel to us
enjoy playing overwatch and keep having
fun thank you
[Music]